opening up America again Donald Trump's
plan to restart the economy while the
corona virus continues to ravage the
country our approach outlines three
phases and restoring our economic life
we are not opening all at once but one
careful step at a time and some states
will be able to open up sooner than
others
some states are not in the kind of
trouble that others are in states should
only start the reopening phases when
they've seen a 14 day decline in cases
and hospitals are no longer in crisis
mode reopening won't happen with the
banging that Trump has been talking
about despite his previous claims of
absolute power the president has now
conceded that it is up to individual
governors to call the shots on how their
states move forward the experts will
tell us the best course of conduct based
on that data no political decisions no
emotional decisions data and science
we're talking about human lives here
business leaders and medical experts are
urging caution they say without mass
testing asymptomatic people could return
to work and spread the virus I would
estimate we're roughly a hundred
thousand times less efficient than we
need to be in testing we need to be
capable of doing
millions of tests per day not tens of
thousands or hundreds of thousands we
have a major failure at the federal
level in providing the resources we need
but the president is impatient watching
his economy fade taking with it his
strongest platform for re-election in
November you can only watch as the job
crisis worsens 22 million Americans have
filed for unemployment in the last four
weeks Donald Trump desperately wants his
economy to start thriving again that may
simp
be impossible while America is still in
the grip of this deadly virus Amanda
Walker Sky News Washington